we were at the ivy last night eating
dinner and there was a loud girl's
birthday like they were you know wo yeah
yeah it was sweet yeah 14 and the okay
older couple next to us older table
people just they were a little annoyed
and eventually the guy just snapped
screamed on to SC shut literally and the
whole room went silent silent at first I
was like ah well whatever they were
being annoying Rift in my but I felt so
bad for them when I saw these girls that
and then like their party was ruined
like it wasn't like they just laughed it
off like I would have when I was 14 like
you old man like I hope he get killed in
an accident on the way home I hope he
died I really do I hated him I don't
know when you're eating in a night a
nice restaurant and people are like the
woo girls you are kind of like do not
there is a little bit going it's about
to have a kid I'm kind of like I had a
con I got pinched as a kid if you were
loud in public you got pinched you
learned to be quiet
teen into just Tik to and you are kind
of like there's no respect for like you
don't even know care that anyone is they
offered to move these people and they
didn't move like he was just one of
those old jerk offs who got even they
left right after of course they
did was just screaming on top of its
lungs and the lady is like saying to the
table the restaurant should have taken
care of this and it's like how many
times have you been here a hundred times
told the guy he was wrong yell him I got
into it with him a little bit I realized
Jim is so good at handling these
situations cuz I'm kind of shaking you
know and I'm feeling so terrible I just
shut up but Jim handles it just also
they were like 25 that's different they
14 like these are children right kids
having a good time and they weren't
being mean even when they were loud they
go sh like they were trying they were
just giggling and having fun and it's a
birthday they sang Happy Birthday and
this Miser Le and his cryptic
wife uh that's exactly what they were
they were old
cryptic dead people and he was a he was
a bully because he he wouldn't have not
have yell if that was Chuck Zito sitting
there he would not have screamed at him
like that and I didn't yell at the old
gu he knew there would be no
ramifications I spoke to him but I
didn't yell at him because again I
wouldn't yell at Chuck Zito either so I
can't yell at a 70-year-old guy so you
went up to him like right away or he was
ta behind Five I couldn't take it
anymore when I saw those girls huddled
and shut I just got so mad I just said
to him I'm like I'm like you know they
were annoying you're right but you I'm
like you didn't have to yell at them
that was you were wrong and he's well
thank you for your advice I'm like if
that was a table full I think I said of
Like Rappers or whatever I'm like you
never would have done that and I know it
you know it you wouldn't have yelled at
men um and then they just got up and
left he was I I literally hope he hole
on the way home
I hat that guy I um I do feel like it's
interesting as like a forward- facing
person like that seemed like it would be
fine I'm always the person that is fight
most people are freeze or flight I'm
always fight like I'm the person who's
like when something's going on like I
always want to get involved yeah and
that's just I think part of our thing
there's I felt that way too I wanted to
say something really bad luckily he
handled it up the sister the sister
finally screamed but Nikki Nikki is so
helpful all these girls were like happy
that we said something and Nikki goes
it's okay she was a sea
word
I'm like
fuck I didn't they're 14 but she said c
word she didn't actually say the word so
you know she did it for her Tonight Show
set she kept
laugh and they said you're cool and I'm
like oh yeah like the cool ant but they
offered yeah they offered us the rest of
their cake you want the rest of the cake
and I did but I couldn't bring home a
14-year-old's cake I was going to say
you'll end up on a list I can't bring
home
14-year-old but the party ended right
after that and they left and then the
birthday girl was there with her like I
just felt bad that the guy yelled he
have he could have they had such said
something nice I I'm very happy that
this is the memory that they will have
cuz at least didn't end with just him
going at least they had people sighting
with them and saying it's F he douche
and you know what it's interesting about
comedians like we get so beat up on for
so many things and people say we're
bullies and we make fun of people at the
end of the day our deal is an obsession
with Justice and calling out hypocrisy
and unfairness so it's like you know
it's like even if we're like defending
Trump or something people like how could
you do that you're like cuz you guys
that wasn't a fair these are fair
allegations but this one's not like we
just are on the side of Justice always
and that was an unfair that was just
unfair and just being yeah and also
being obsessed like whenever I see
somebody just doing something because it
looks like that's what works on their
side of the or or that's what my hive
says it's just kind of annoy we're kind
of we bully the bullies I feel like
that's kind of our thing do you know
what I mean a weird way like that's
always the we go in a way and that guy
was like a bully he was a bully because
not because he spoke up or because he
was annoyed cuz they were being a little
irritating but just the way he did it
and it's like you never would have
yelled at certain other people like that
and I know it and you know it but again
for the same reason I couldn't yell at
him I would scream like I said chug Zito
so I wasn't going to yell at an old guy
I spoke to him the way I would have
spoke to anybody else and let me just
ask you of just the the getting mad at
people in traffic like what comes up
like what is it it's it's a weird is it
primordial is it a wound it's like
whenever whenever I hear about a road
rage shooting uhuh I always have a let's
wait and see
attitude let me see the footage